[Music]  Kylie Jenner surprises fans at prom the  19 year old reality star and her BFF  Jordan woods popped up at the Rio  americano high school prom in Sacramento  California on Saturday night though the  famous ladies only stayed at 30 minutes  student Sam Adams tells ET we had no  idea she was going to show up it was a  huge surprise everyone went crazy and of  course reality show cameras were there  to capture every moment is Kylie mingled  and took photos with the senior class  Kylie is said to have been there as a  date of senior student Alberta Choa she  looked gorgeous in a long nude gown and  see-through strappy heels even rocking  accros are the special occasion while  jordan also wore a croissant a beautiful  ruby red gown  [Music]  you